-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers.
This is "Late Night. We hope
you're doing well tonight.
Now, if you don't mind,
we're going to get to the news.
President Biden announced today
that he is running
for reelection.
Can you imagine if it's
Biden versus Trump again?
That's like going into a diner
and the only things on the menu
are two-day-old egg salad
and Donald Trump.
[ Laughter ]
I guess I'll take my chances
with the egg salad.
President Biden announced today
that it will run for
a second term and said,
"Let's finish the job."
Yeah, good idea.
It would be nice
to have a country
where a guy could safely
retire before he's 86.
[ Laughter ]
Following President Biden's
reelection announcement today,
the Republican National
Committee released
an ad that asks,
"What if the weakest president
we've ever had were reelected?"
And personally, I think
it's pretty low to drag
Martin Van Buren into this.
[ Laughter ]
Life's hard enough
with that silly haircut.
According to reports.
Fox News CEO Suzanne Scott
did not tell Tucker Carlson
why he was being fired,
but said that the decision
was made "from above."
But come on, we know all
the decisions at Fox News
come from below.
[ Laughter ]
The Georgia...
[ Cheers and applause ]
The Georgia prosecutor
investigating former
President Trump's
alleged interference
into the 2020 election
said yesterday
that she would announce
potential charges this summer.
I like that we're spreading out
Trump's crimes
and just, like, microdosing
indictments, you know?
Because like when Netflix drops
an entire season at once,
sure, it's fun that weekend,
but then we have nothing
to look forward to.
Once a week is way better.
It's like Trump's
the "Abbott Elementary"
of criminals.
[ Laughter ]
A man in Idaho recently sent
a Guinness World Record
after he passed
a 40-pound weight
from hand to hand 100 times.
That story, again,
not much to do in Idaho.
[ Laughter ]
He didn't even know
Guinness was there.
[ Laughter ]
And they were, like, Hey, how
many times have you done that?
A moose -- A moose.
We like when it starts a moose.
A moose recently walked into
a movie theater in Alaska
and ate popcorn
from the trash can,
or, as Regal Cinemas
calls it, a medium.
[ Laughter ]
Now movie theaters,
you used to...
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a former Disney
World employee
was recently arrested
for allegedly
taking videos
of women's skirts.
To be fair, they should have
known something was wrong
when he showed up to work
with no pants on.
[ Laughter ]
That was a monologue,
everybody.
We are off and running.
We've got a fantastic show
for you tonight.
He is a Tony and Emmy
winning legend
currently on Broadway
at Studio 54
in "Pictures From Home,"
our friend Nathan Lane
is here tonight, everybody.
[ Cheers and applause ]
She is a California
congresswoman
and candidate for Senate.
Her book, "I Swear:
Politics is Messier
Than My Minivan"
is out now
Congresswoman Katie Porter
is back on the show.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And direct from the
Sondheim Theater on Broadway,
we're going to have
a performance
from the new hit show
"& Juliet."
You're going to love it.
We'll get to that.
You guys,
spring is in the air,
flowers are blooming,
birds are chirping,
everyone is stocking up
on Benadryl.
And that includes my writers.
You know, my writing staff,
they write hundreds
of monologue jokes every day
just to get the 10 or 12
we end up using.
And sometimes...
I think they throw
in a few stinkers
just to get their numbers up
and meet the assignment.
[ Laughter ]
But just because pollen levels
are through the roof,
that doesn't mean
we can tolerate laziness,
which means it's time
for another Surprise Inspection.
[ Bugle call ]
♪♪
Alright,
so here's how this works.
I'm going to read
some real jokes
that were really submitted
by my writers to me, their boss.
These jokes are unusable
for this show.
Some are dumb,
some are offensive,
some are just confusing.
And most importantly,
this is the most important part,
my writers don't know
we're doing this,
and because most of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know.
[ Laughter ]
So let's get started.
Vice President Kamala Harris
participated in a roundtable
discussion today
about reproductive rights
in Des Moines, Iowa.
Because women who think
they might want to have a child
deserve the right
to change "their minds".
[ Laughter ]
That was written
by Matt Goldich. There he is.
[ Laughter, applause ]
Des Moines.
I mean, obviously,
it doesn't work.
Maybe if anybody, if any --
the slang for their minds
was ever Des Moines.
I'm sure this next one
will bounce us right back.
Today was ABBA singer
Bjorn Ulvaeus 78th birthday.
Wow, it's hard to believe
he was "bjorn" in 1945.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
Apologies.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know if you applaud
you're just going
to get more of this.
According to a new study,
quality of sleep
can positively impact
quality of life.
"Uh, you're welcome,"
said Bill Cosby.
[ Laughter, audience oohs ]
No applause that time?
[ Laughter ]
I liked Bjorn for born,
but I didn't.,,
[ Laughter ]
That was written
by Mike Scollins,
who's a bad guy.
[ Laughter ]
That's a --
that was a photo.
It was was taken
after he shoved a kid
and people got mad at him.
He was like, "Hey."
[ Laughter ]
A high school principal
in Florida,
recently resigned
after she received criticism
from parents
for showing sculpture
Michelangelo's -- sorry,
go back -- for showing students,
excuse me --
Well, I made a mistake here.
You know what?
So when this joke stinks,
it's still not my fault.
[ Laughter ]
A high school principal
in Florida
recently resigned
after she received criticism
from parents
for showing students
Michelangelo's sculpture David
in direct violation
of the state's
don't say gray law.
[ Audience moan ]
So is that because --
Do we think that
because a statue's gray?
That I -- I'm hoping that was
written by ChatGPT and not...
[ Laughter ]
Show me ChatGPT!
Oh [bleep]!
[ Laughter ]
Brian also did Bjorn.
Imagine...
Imagine your day is over,
and the best thing you did
was the Bjorn joke
[ Laughter ]
Authorities in France found
nearly 2,000 pounds of cocaine
this week on a beach
in the English Channel.
"Oops, sorry.
That's mine," said a whale.
[ Laughter ]
It feels like it got --
it was like almost like --
right when it became
almost got to a joke,
Karen here was like,
"I'm good."
[ Laughter ]
Like,
a whale with a neck tattoo.
Like maybe, right?
Whale with pair of Ray-Bans
working on a screenplay, maybe.
Right? Just a whale,
because Karen saw it.
She's like,
That's a lot of cocaine.
It's on a beach.
What's something equally big?
A whale.
When she got to that part,
she was just like, "Send."
[ Laughter ]
Karen, interestingly,
our smallest writer,
which is why whenever
a little bit of cocaine
goes missing.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
A pilot -- a pilot
in South Africa
recently had to make
an emergency landing
after he spotted a venomous
snake under his seat.
Even worse, the snake took its
shoe off for the whole flight.
[ Light laughter ]
[ Laughter ]
So the idea --
the key part of this joke
is that a snake would
only be able to wear one shoe.
The problem with it
is all of us know
they don't wear shoes at all.
[ Laughter ]
That was Ian.
That's -- that's the face
he makes when a very
dim light bulb goes off
over his head.
[ Laughter ]
It was announced last week
that a second Peppa Pig
theme park will open in Texas,
but make sure to come early
because they sell out
pretty fast.
[ Audience groans ]
Yeah, she's not real.
[ Laughter ]
That was -- Who was that?
There we go.
[ Laughter ]
He is, as they say, on fire.
That's actually what
HR has told us
we can't do to him.
[ Laughter ]
Can we set him on fire?
They're like, No.
Okay, you guys,
Karen's back.
I'm just going to spoil it
say Karen's going
to try to bounce back
after after whale gate.
[ Laughter ]
An artist in Australia
recently set
a Guinness World record
for the widest wig.
"Finally," said Charlie Brown.
[ Light laughter ]
So I guess the idea is
he's got a big ol' wide head
and that he's long wanted
to wear a wig.
And then this was good news.
[ Light laughter ]
And I don't know.
[ Laughter ]
I feel like doesn't
even work a [bleep] tiny bit.
[ Laughter ]
Oh, this is going to be
a good one, compared.
The Justice Department
has filed a lawsuit
against the drugstore Rite Aid
that alleges it violated
the Controlled Substances Act
and said the company
"knowingly filled
unlawful prescriptions."
So needless to say,
many former Rite Aid employees
are going to have to work
on their CVs.
[ Light laughter,
audience groaning ]
Ooh, you know --
you know how people
in America when they lose
their jobs say,
"Well, I best work
on my CV."
[ Laughter ]
Show me Ian.
[ Applause ]
Today was molecular
biologist James Watson's.
95th birthday.
Wow, 95.
He must have some crick
in his neck.
Like, not even know --
no part of this.
So Watson and crick,
you know,
they got
the double helix here.
You know, they discover it.
But why does he, having
a crick in his neck,
Why does that mean
he's living longer?
I just feel like Allie --
let's show Allie --
just like some words
appeared to her.
She was like Watson.
She was like,
oh, of Watson and Crick,
and then a part
of her brain was like,
"Oh, Crick."
[ Laughter ]
[ Whispering "Allie, Allie like
a crick in your neck."
[ Laughter ]
She was like,
"No, shut up, brain.
That doesn't make any sense."
And her brain was like,
"No, it'll work really good."
She's said, "Hmm.
Is this our last one?
Yeah, this is the last one.
We often go to Scollins
for our closers,
and that's what
we're doing here today.
Scollins -- we've
seen Scollins 'once before
and it was the --
it was a Cosby joke,
which was everyone's favorite.
[ Laughter ]
Today was National Napping Day,
said parents who weren't ready
to tell the truth about grandma.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Light laughter ]
What?
What? No, no, no.
There you are.
There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You don't get it.
You guys, what a time we've had.
This has been
Surprise Inspection.
[ Bugle call ]
♪♪